[Music]
so working on a warhammer 40 000 license
especially space marine 2 is it's an
amazing honor and i'm very excited about
it there are millions of people that
love this franchise
and one of the scary things about this
franchise is that there are millions of
people that love this franchise
we didn't just want to create
any third person shooter we wanted to
create a game that embodied the galactic
warfare that you you come to know from
this franchise it is a passion piece for
all of the people working at sabre
you know these are people who've read
the novels for years who've played the
games and so nobody has higher
expectations than us
i'm playing physically what amounts to
like a super galactic space warrior you
know these guys are two and a half
meters tall they're probably about 500
pounds before you even put the armor on
top of them and their armor
is ginormous how do you recreate that
and then you see it you know suddenly i
am two and a half meters tall and um
it's pretty amazing most human beings in
this world will never see a space marine
they're the stuff of legends they're
known as the angels of death his angels
when one appears on a battlefield it's
like seeing an angel of god well titus
you know he's been there done that seen
more than all the other ultramarines
he's an apex predator yeah everything he
does with purpose everything with
intention everything with extreme power
people who've read the books will have
expectations about how space millions
fight and so that's been our guiding
principle behind the gameplay that we
created
one of my favorite parts of the trailer
release at the game awards was watching
the feedback that people gave afterwards
and i saw all this excitement over just
a tiny few snippets of gameplay and i
just kept thinking wait till you see
what we got for you wait till you see
what's next
you